yeah welcome to this video let's see
what I can do in this game yeah I have
to say I'm I'm completely pissed and I
hope to I mean that guy's has no nothing
to do with it but I really want to want
to punish someone the reason is that i
lost about two hours of video that I
recorded blitz games and rapid games and
I lost it because my job what can i say
my recording software it it just didn't
record I mean it everything looked like
normal and it produced some files but
the files were simply unusable there was
no real video on it so um yeah i'm i
just i just spent quite a bit of time
for absolutely nothing so and this is
what i really hate yeah i absolutely
hate spending time on something and then
do we have to do it all over again and
this is what happens here i need to play
those games again i mean i like to play
but really two hours gone anyway so
let's see what happens we have a semi
slavia against mr. mock why um yeah I
think why does is quite okay 95 okay so
yeah let's let's take I really I don't
don't want to Train Queen so much but I
couldn't really avoid it may be queen
age for wasn't the best possible move in
retrospect um in general his setup is
pretty pretty bad but with Queens traded
it might be might be M might be a
somewhat batam yeah okay I can do this
that's possible now all of a sudden now
Queen trader some is really not not not
great nothing that I'm that that helps
me
yeah it's difficult to cover before
Renee I can take here take a five but
it's very had somewhat too meek now
Queen h4 was wrong that's a bit bit
annoying because we're a setup was
really bad with allowing c5 and you form
it's completely anti positional to do
that but okay Queen edge for Watson late
and therefore it's not that great my
position I mean it's good but nothing
nothing brilliant okay I tried Bishop to
c5 oh he doesn't do anything against
that let's do let's go here
yeah we should press if I it's going to
be a problem
and you don't really see how he defends
against that here we go yeah i can go a
five everything else fails but yeah
that's going in five wins the exchange
at least night see for Bishop 87
yeah black resins just was just lose
this material quite a bit yeah it was a
bit Queen h4 was probably just a bad
idea the reason why I said that this is
anti positional is that here black house
is very bad bishop on b7 I have a pretty
substantial space advantage she has wide
I have 95 as a possibility sometimes
also bishop p.m. it's just a much more
comfortable position for white and black
shouldn't allow this kind of structure
just not very good the problem was that
i made a mistake here i played queen age
for very very quickly and as it is so
often if you play very quickly it's not
a good move this is better anticipating
a 5 and after this now I have some more
options I don't need to take now on b6
it is a move but I don't need to take I
can also just keep them the structure as
is with something like this for example
this would have been better so here ya
g3 was because of night f4 looking
looking problematic no here yeah I think
I'm okay yeah but it wasn't what I what
I intended to do yeah I also expected
this looks more natural the ruckus kind
of Miss place now Bishop here back a
foil and it's a bit better for white but
he definitely has to avoid Knight b6 I
think that losses right ham that loses
straight away due to Bishop e3 and
Bishop c5 after that well he can resign
and he actually did resign he has to
play on something else um the engine is
suggesting to go rook to e8 just
stepping out of Bishop e3 that just
makes some sense through here yeah I'm a
bit better those bishops are not very
active the ccc 6 porn is weak but this
is nothing serious so certainly a
defensible
position for black okay well thanks for
watching